[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
the m word first time i ever heard the
n-word i was at
uh i was i was in first grade and
these black kids came into our
neighborhood we lived in like a poor
white neighborhood and there was a poor
black neighborhood
like across across across nebraska or
not nebraska
i forget well dude that's pretty far
then
no no no no that was the street name not
the oh right ombre yeah
and so damn this dude did not live by
black people if he said they [ __ ]
lived a state away
so they're like wow they were in
nebraska and we were in florida and it
was scary man
i gotta be honest with you it was touch
and go at times
i mean we heard stories oh yeah the
rumor mill i saw a note in a bottle one
time in the river
it was crazy watch out for the blacks
they're coming up over your shoulders
there's a dad in our neighborhood who uh
you'd play [ __ ] with him and if
and if you lost the letter instead of
losing a letter you had to kiss him
i remember feeling like hey i remember
illegal bro
no [ __ ] back then you just didn't know
you're like ah
i gotta kiss this down did you get some
lips or small of his back
i don't remember i want to say on the
cheek but maybe sometimes on the lips
i don't remember damn dude that's even
get that's
is that gay or just [ __ ] up i don't
know remember you you definitely did not
want to miss shots
it really made competition [ __ ]
intense bro his team shot
seventy percent from three point range i
remember he'd make a shot and it would
be like
[ __ ] get the chapstick out
so these these black kids lived across
this this main street from us and then
they came into our neighborhood i guess
and stole my football my football had a
duke junior
with a shoelace a tan shoelace as the
strings we was playing the street
and so the string for the shoelace
ripped my dad replaced it with a
with a with a tan shoelace it was very
distinguishable and a little part we
couldn't tie it so there was a little
like
part of the chicken show yeah so they
came into our
neighborhood and they asked if they
wanted to play us a football and they
had my football
and these two brothers daryl and darren
like yo they're
they must i mean i when i remember this
story i feel like they're 18 17.
they're probably just like 10 11. yeah
and i was six
yeah and they were like yo this is
football and they're like
no this is his football this little
other little black kid
and they're like fight him for it and i
was like i have first grade i was not
fighting anyone i was wearing a
loincloth and knee-high moccasins
oh yeah and so um he's fighting your
sexuality bruh
my dad's like get him some knee pads
he's gonna be sucking dick
so uh so yeah so he's gonna need knee
pads to do it what a [ __ ]
that's crazy
what about the good old days man well
you would suck dick
your knees and your [ __ ] dick be a
man about it yeah bro support the union
you freak what kind of gay guy puts on
knee pads
like a man man a backup gay dude you
mind if i pull my socks up
then the whole thing is then it turns
into the boardroom with donald trump
whatever that
show the apprentice yeah the apprentice
so they bring us into the inn they bring
me
amy and mo in and it's greg louganis and
michael ian black
and he real quick cruises through mo and
amy he's like moe
your dive was a little offensive amy it
was inconsequential bert
i understand you're married and i went i
am and he was with children
and i said i am and he goes you're not a
gay man and i went
no and he was like do you realize how
offensive it is
to hit on a gay man and lead him on and
make him think you were gay because i
was legit hitting on greg logan as the
whole [ __ ] episode like even low key
hitting on him
even when the cameras were off i was
flirting with him wow thinking like if
he thinks
you know whatever right right if he
thinks i might be able to [ __ ] he might
give me an extra you know yeah and he
was like and and i
think it was edited out but i think the
thing i go greg
you have aids i would do you think i was
hitting on you
and he was like he was like you're fired
and he just gets up and leaves
and amy and mo are like oh my god
they're like what the [ __ ] did we just
witness
and then they're like moe and amy are
dismissed and they get up and they walk
out
and then michael and black goes uh bert
you've made a lot of bad life
decisions by the way he's mike's michael
and black's not even joking at this
point right and i was like yeah
and he goes your body your hair i mean
your facial hair like he's picking me
apart
yeah and i'm like yeah and by the way
and no joke i am humiliated this moment
because i had driven all of us down
remember i drove us all down
and in the car ride down amy said oh my
god what if one of us gets kicked off
how awkward would the drive back be and
i was like oh my god i gotta drive
everyone [ __ ] home
and so he goes uh michael and black's
like
oh i'm gonna need your trunks your suit
and i was like okay
and so i get up and i'm just embarrassed
and i'm trying to make it funny and i
don't know how to
so i knock over each of the chairs and
he goes what are you doing and i said
i make big exits michael and he was like
no there's no music playing in this okay
michaelian black's yeah i mean really
talented kind of a [ __ ] though but he's
and he's really straight yeah this whole
thing was like straight man
yeah always and i take my robe off
and then i take my trunks off and i'm
naked and he's like wow he's like
and he might be home or he's not even
joking at this moment he's like i
wouldn't do that
and by the way there's a 30 person film
crew there yeah filming this
i get on the table and i put my feet on
the back of his chair and i start
pulling his face into my junk
and he's like no no he's like i go look
at it michael and he goes i'm afraid
i'll turn to stone i go part of you will
yeah and then
it is awkward it is uncomfortable at
this moment and i look at him
and in the last ditch effort i kick and
i do a backspin
naked and i stick it on the table and i
look at him
and [ __ ] thank you michael m
black breaks character and starts
laughing hysterically
and the whole set starts laughing and i
walk off
i was i drive him around campus and like
a k-car do you remember a k-car
pull up a k-car can you it was like the
[ __ ] the biggest beater you could
ever have yeah i think it's called a
k-car or q-car
it's like an old yeah yeah yeah yeah
that was it
oh yeah renault that's a that's a
renault isn't it
chrysler k that was uh that was but it
was white
and so and then they would what would
happen is
you knew if the black chicks called on a
saturday night because you it was just
taking people to the library is where
you're supposed to go
okay but if the black chicks called on a
saturday night you knew
they wanted to go to famu from florida
state okay and we weren't allowed to
drive to famu but once they got in the
car you had to take them wherever they
went so what would happen is they go
they go we have a pickup at devony hall
well based 111 i have a pickup at deputy
hall
her name's laquisha and you go okay
you'd be like is it how many passengers
are like just one that's what they say
and so you'd pull up and then she'd like
wave to you
and you go hey and as she waved they'd
pile in the other side of the car and
shake it in they go we're going to fam
you [ __ ]
i loved it though because i because i
love hip hop and when did you guys start
making love or you'd already been making
love
no we don't even make it yeah we we had
sex probably like
five days in this back during sex in the
city remember that sex in the city run
where all guys thought all girls were
[ __ ]
i remember thinking that though just
even looking on instagram so
there was a period where women were like
and that thing is still there but like
sex and the city came out and women are
like yeah i like to [ __ ]
oh i could see that like now we're in
control of our own [ __ ] and that
scared the [ __ ] out of me because i've
only had sex with six people
women why am i saying people women adult
women
adult women first joke i wrote about the
girls was um
isla was a baby and she had
uh she they woke up early in the morning
i go downstairs i hear my baby mother go
downstairs
i'm like what's going on why are you
laughing george is in a rocket chair i
list naked
and uh george is like dad you got to see
baby atlas new trick the dog's in
between them like i don't [ __ ] know
and i go what is it she goes i don't
want to spoil it for you eyelash show
dad
and isla takes her finger shoves it up
her ass and puts it in the dog's mouth
oh and that's the first joke i wrote
about my daughters
the jolly roger we call the happy nazi
and so i had to run the period joke past
highland she was uh
did you sit down and talk to her about
it i told her i put it here's what
you know me man i put her on [ __ ]
instagram stories the day it happened so
the day it happened
she gets her period she wants to a
period party do they do that now
oh yeah it's big time what
oh yeah a period party yeah i told part
of the story on conan
and it went viral i told just a part of
the story on conan
and it got 20 million views immediately
so like
she go she's like i mean i want to ruin
it watch this special but
she i i get i get all the stuff for the
period party i dress in red
what like [ __ ] red velvet cake
[ __ ]
yeah dude that's what i said that's what
i said dude you're gonna love dude
you'll love this bit you'll love this
bit
but my point is i put it all on
instagram stories that night because i'm
laughing
i'm dying laughing and then i get in bed
that night she comes in she's like hey
big boy i need you to take that down
and i go what i go baby it's it's it's
fine i think it's cool
she goes yeah i know i i don't mind
people knowing i threw a period party
but i don't want kids in my school
knowing i had my period yeah and i went
oh okay that makes sense so i pull it
all down
and then i go to louisville that next
weekend and i talk about it i try it on
stage
and just that just that reaction you
just had is the whole room's habit
[Music]
ain't place